des projectiles des grenades
lacrymogènes
la scène est saisissante certains
manifestants affrontent les forces de
l'ordre sur la place de la gare à
montbéliard des jeunes se sont
introduits sur la voie ferrée uni de
ballast projeter sur les gendarmes et
policiers très vite la situation
dégénère haïtien est blessé à la tête
lors d'une altercation avec les forces
de l'ordre
rapidement pris en charge par les
pompiers selon la préfecture le jeune
homme a regagné son domicile en début
d'après midi
je voulais pas cette violence tout cette
présence policière ces gens qui
provoquent ça sert à rien franchement ça
sert vraiment à rien parce que nous on
est du côté pacifiste voyez regardez
c'est tout comme et là bas ça provoque
sa provoc et après c'est sûr qu'ils se
reçoivent des bons mais là par contre je
veux bien comprendre que les crs ils
défendent au deuxième jour de
mobilisation à montbéliard il est lycéen
maintiennent leur revendication
protestation contre la réforme du bac et
parcours sup n'est pas seulement les
étudiants étrangers vont aussi par
exemple payer plus cher leurs études et
moi je trouve ça juste je sais pas il
n'y a pas de mots pour décrire ça pour
moi c'est juste pas possible on est tous
on est tous sur le même territoire on
doit tous payer la même chose liberté
égalité fraternité
et ces valeurs qui sont plus appliquées
aujourd'hui encore à mon sens mes grands
parents et ma mère galères et très
souvent aussi pour l'égalité parce que
la devise de la france et l'égalité la
fraternité la liberté et aujourd'hui je
suis là pour l'égalité parce que la
france devrait on devrait tous être
égaux
selon les forces de l'ordre trois jeunes
ont été interpellés n'est quelques 300
manifestants se sont dispersés en fin
matinée
[Musique]